welcome to this video is so called yam
and played the sky before I have
forgotten what it was I think I'd wide
right ok jack bogle what did we have a
poco as well I it was involved it was a
weird game yeah well yeah I remember
where we're screwed up terribly he
played a very strange setup him i
remember i'm eager to repeat that you
plead night be 3 which is just just a
strange move but maybe maybe plays it
again i don't know i just play it again
right it's very rare that night ever
belongs on b3 in any Queens Indian bogo
Indian whatever structure but the poor
not be 6 night on b3 is always looking a
bit silly it's comparable to a night on
g3 when this g 6 plate this is also
normally not making much sense but of
course White's position is very solid
she can play this kind of well so-and-so
moves and without being being worse ok
let's kick this and maybe get the bishop
am that's not a big deal of course the
bishop am in this position it's very
closed
okay so he for some reason tries to open
the position yeah the thing is he has a
space advantage in the center with the
pawn on e5 so opening the center is is
possible okay that I did not expect
going to take them and then the check
ham on b7 check hmm actually forgot that
he has this move I mean as I saw that
yes a move but I thought that if I take
night takes it was stupid the problem is
the the the week the week square on c6
and I thought that isn't a problem but
it is a problem I came how do I am how
do I play that I need to maybe prepare
might be aid
ships c5 and I can play Knight B 898
Bishop t 497 check unfortunately
yeah that's not very nice to be
perfectly honest ah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's the worst possible nightmare
yeah it's um the worst part is that it's
so easy to play for white I mean very
easy to play you
yeah it's just totally lost them you can
whatever you want this is just
completely lost look doubles on the
default have it it was a gay three queen
bee soundcheck night queen of three is
really what why does he take this is a
joke right this is just totally terrible
no I'm back in the game check I mean I'm
still worse but how can you take now I
have at least some hope I mean not much
hope but bit of hope okay I was totally
boxed and if it's not taking I'm totally
totally done I mean here he may be as
well but at least I mean I can pack and
play moves which wasn't really possible
in the other another continuation ok
count it's still bad round it's still
very bad time morning yeah I know now I
could even play this nonsense move
taking what I have six and still wins
this is how bad it was
check and still it's still it's still
lost not much to do check
I don't get it what what is he doing him
I cannot take check I should have taken
b3m I'm an idiot yeah now is again
winning this which is drinking on the
edge of being undeserved after letting
me back into the game I mean I totally
totally played like an idiot jump and
but what what what did it is also a
pretty terrible letting me back and do
this black resigns John died don't know
maybe it's probably still lost and it is
so so bad yeah but i mean i mean this is
this is unspeakable yeah you cannot take
their it's just terribly bad yeah and I
can make it can even take he should be
six then I even I'm back in the game
completely back in the game yeah what a
bad game from both sides really if it's
not you know if he does this this I just
resign he goes to the seven and over I
have no moves I'm totally paralyzed in
this position and of course taking us
you know okay and of course what editors
is completely completely bonkers totally
totally bad plane so who do I am how do
I make sure that I'm not in this bad
shape I have to start with Bishop c5
here so this is still ok I mean it
definitely was okay before I did this
this is just a normal position there's
nothing going on I mean
any move basically or something I just I
just have must avoid exactly what
happened in the am I just checked
basically played it to make it a
textbook is a textbook kind of game and
then he yeah for whatever reason took on
f6 can edit here I really am out of
movie I have no I have no way out here
we get to this position and I mean just
to show how bad this is if you have a
hard time to even move let's say I play
this I don't know here what's my move I
mean this now this is stale media and he
took he took on f6 I mean okay Bishop f6
was was also a mistake I was hoping okay
getting the bishop out and so on but of
course i have to take with the pawn here
and then i have bishop t6 this kind of
thing and worse I know but this is kind
of this is still I can still fight here
let's set stopped not easy I mean King
King f7 route 28 whatever I will lose
opponents the worse okay but the other
thing is just winning it's very
important to recognize that here rook to
e3 just wins I mean taking us I mean
okay and in TF silver us yeah much worse
but I have to take with the pawn I was
so shocked that he took weather care to
take with the pawn and still I mean I
can somewhat continue but yeah it was
really really bad that I allowed this
what what exactly I can also but it's
the comp also gave that this was still
ok
yeah the point is if you that I get this
in now right hmm and this is still a bit
annoying this position but not a big
problem now this is a second I can draw
relatively comfortably Wow okay what a
what a horror game okay thanks for
watching